I get back to the hotel and smoke the
joint laid down and then they're like do
you want to open for Dave Chappelle is
this you got to be here in 30 minutes I
was like [__] yeah
yeah it was one of the best experience
in my life and I really think the fact
that I had been like repped so hard so I
didn't freak out it was the first time I
fully felt that like I could turn a tide
because they did not want to see me
because they have been waiting years
it's not just like oh Dave was here last
week or you know he was here two years
ago it was like we have been waiting
almost a decade to hear what he has to
say and we got to listen to this
[__] first that's what it's like
being an opener
two jokes in I turned them and I [__]
they were listening to me